hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
now there's nothing like watching a dota
player pull off a true 200 IQ play
something so brilliantly big brained
that it either escapes fans entirely or
causes them to roar with excitement
[Applause]
now for our purposes we're defining a
200 IQ play as one that both massively
impacts the game and makes you think
twice about how it was conceived
sometimes it's so subtle that the
casters don't even pick up on it other
times it's loud in your face and
immediately etched into the annals of
dota2 history here's our list coming in
at number 10 is one of the most infamous
plays in dota 2 history no tide hunters
next level roshan bait seriously it
takes some big brain 200 IQ [ __ ] to
think up this one and wow admiralbulldog
give it a freebie and here we go uh-huh
game is on the bait is lame there's a
small blood patch with Admiral bull get
the giraffe
and it is is that you're trapped because
they came to check for it now this gun
big guys that I've known they gotta
bring it
my games now what the beat is the Swedes
may pull something out of the bag ten
feet is gonna go down as well Oh
tidehunter oughta stop what a strategy
coming out from a total empty after
seeing admiralbulldog died - Roshan evil
geniuses were led to believe that no
tidehunter were attempting to kill
Roshan at level one and doing what any
other team in the situation would do
evil geniuses ran in to contest it but
the pigs was empty waiting to spring the
trap
no tidehunter flanked the retreating
evil genius squad and secured themselves
two kills along with a spot in dota twos
history books no one has ever done that
no one has ever done that in the history
of dota coming in at number nine is
infamous double song of the siren closer
against vgj thunder in the semi-finals
of GE SC Indonesia
despite securing mega creeps infamous
were having trouble closing out the game
that is until Schofield caught vgj
Thunder outside their base with a
perfectly placed song of the sirens 6.75
second the sole down the song they
managed to catch a look can they get
some sort of perfect Saturday they're
bringing in the rest of the team the
eyes pop is down it's gonna catch on to
three month of the base as well that's
the second story today
the pressures on
swap duration its
Jiji
the couple's own Schofield
go to the Naga siren finally
coming in at number eight is a moment
that won't soon be forgotten since it
was more than just a genius play props
to fanatics for the 200 IQ play but the
real MVP guys for their hype how many
Chow real lines did you count they're
coming in at number 7 is moon meanders
double-kill turnaround from TI 5's
group-stage
pushing deep under the enemy's tier 1
tower moon finds himself in a tricky
situation with MVP trapping him inside
disruptors kinetic field but instead of
trying to run away moon stands his
ground and takes them all on by himself
moon is clearly thinking a couple of
steps ahead of his opponents here as she
instantly levels off his hook shot the
moment he reaches level 6 and uses it to
secure a double kill before falling
next up at number six is boba cos monkey
king tree Juke against teamliquid at DAC
2017 realizing his team is nearby
boba ki uses himself as bait and secures
his team a double kill on miracle and
matumbo man and doesn't even need to die
for it
multiple ankles were broken on this one
okay I'm gonna jump in on some atooma
man miracles there as well I was the bad
with the stun trust you can't seem to
right-click him they lose the nature's
prophet IG they'll never see it come out
coming up at number 5 is bone sevens
courier snipe against c-deck in TI 5s
quarter finals series more than anything
is you kind of saw the weakness and Cena
see duck is that they were a little bit
too afraid to go for anything but bone
seven is gonna try to select the career
it's not enraged oh oh these are the
next level strats big for cloud nine
but seven suicide event it doesn't help
betting his gold by putting the point in
to teleport at level one and using smoke
of deceit beforehand bone7 was able to
infiltrate the enemy base and take out
seed ex courier before the game even
started that's some cloud 9 [ __ ] if I've
ever seen it new life will make his home
amongst your vote up next at number four
is another base race courtesy of fnatic
this time against Evil Geniuses with iOS
level 25 talons a deciliter reducing the
building's armor and a bottled double
damage rune on eternal envies morphling
there was simply nothing EG could do to
stop this from happening
stuff for himself and a cheap stuff for
each in is going it right for night or
not it fanatic no to HP I'm gonna came
back up odds are doing it that's another
tube stock
backdoor protection ain't got nothing on
this
these showing he's not the selfish
player everyone thinks he is is none
other than sumail and his blood stone
deny against vici gaming in the group
stage of the International 2015 with an
empty mana pool sumail realizes that the
only way he can keep fighting is to die
and buy back into the game and what
better way to do that than deny yourself
with bloodstone not only did it prevent
giving away a kill to VG but it also
heals his team in the process
I needed a break anyway coming in at the
runner-up spot is no one's big brain
sunstrike hill ons i zeus in the
semi-finals of ESL 1 Homburg 2018 now I
know most mid laners have their team's
fortification glyphs set to a hotkey to
help secure CS advantage in the laning
phase but this play by no-one is truly
some next-level [ __ ]
zài as he's at Seraph games on the
offline 50 whatever
that'd be bottom he presses app presses
app the crypts are glitched to his trap
in between three grits and he gets
unstuck oh my god
coming up at number one is one of the
most impactful and yet unnoticed plays
of all time caught out of position while
farming ancients ana desperately makes
his way to the secret shop and sells
some of his items in order to have
enough gold for buy back all the while
LGD is killing let's see that one more
time from Ana's perspective hey I see
Zhanna farming these agents right now
FY just giving so much information for
the team he's got eyes on him
at the punch or the wrong target at the
snowball possible cut out seriously if
it weren't for his split-second
decision-making og would have lost the
game and LGD would be taking home the
aegis instead
it doesn't get any higher stakes than
that well guys that's our list be sure
to let us know in the comments if there
are any big brain plays etched in your
memory that we forgot to include be sure
to LIKE the video subscribe to our
Channel and we'll see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]
you